-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
It is time to play
a game of deception called
"True Confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My first opponent tonight
is a Yankee legend
and the founder and chairman of
the Turn 2 Foundation.
Please welcome Derek Jeter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow! You nailed that.
You came right --
sliding right in.
-Yes.
-Derek and I will be
facing off against
an incredibly
talented singer-songwriter,
whose new single,
"You Only Love Me,"
is out now.
Please welcome Rita Ora!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh!
It is so good to see you both.
Come on, now.
That's exactly what
I'm talking about.
-This is great.
-Before we start,
what's in the cup?
-Alright, no, no, this is real
coffee in the cup.
Yeah, here we go.
This is like
a real old-timey detective.
-Oh it is.
It smells like coffee, too.
-Yeah, I wouldn't --
No, don't drink it.
-Okay, okay. Sorry.
-It's not really coffee.
Alright, here's how this works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true. The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then you have to come to
a unanimous decision --
is it the truth or is it a lie?
-Why is the only song
in my head right now
that should
suit this segment is...
♪ These are my confessions ♪
♪ Just when I thought I said ♪
I feel like you should do that.
-I should do that?
-Yeah.
-You've gotta teach me
how to sing and dance.
Okay, here we go.
-ADHD, ADHD.
-I think, Derek,
you go first, okay?
Which envelope should he open?
1 or 2?
-Pick 2!
-Of course, everyone's -- Wow,
I didn't even think about that.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Number 2, yeah.
-Do you have anything stronger
than that coffee?
-Really, okay, here we go.
-Oh.
-You're Derek Jeter.
-Yeah.
-We would have known.
-But I'm sure you have, like,
a really well-sculpted bottom.
Do you know what I mean?
-Were you talking to me or you
were looking at Derek?
-Sorry. I meant you.
-Thank you.
-Alright.
-Wait, what --
-Is that a question?
-Thousands -- Where?
Where were there
thousands of people?
-In New York.
-Yeah, in New York.
-Yes.
-Were you wearing the thong
where one would wear a thong?
-Where else would you
wear a thong?
-I don't know,
but I thought maybe, like,
it was a weird trick question
or something.
-I wore it where
one would wear a thong, yes.
-So, do you wear underwear?
-Ooh!
-I do.
-In general.
-Okay.
So you've never gone, like --
-Obviously.
-You have your own line of
underwear, don't you?
Athletic wear.
-Athletic, yeah.
-But these weren't your --
Was it your thong?
-No, it was not my thong.
-Wow!
-It was not my thong.
-It was not your thong.
Did you have anything else on?
-I don't believe him.
I don't believe him.
-Did you have anything else on?
-I did.
-So, now we pick, right?
We choose, we decide.
-Yeah, what do you think?
I say --
-I say no. I say lie.
-I say lie.
[ Drumroll ]
-It is the truth.
-Wait.
What are you talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What?! How did...
What are you talking about?
-Hold on, hold on. Hold --
Wait wait, wait.
-What in the world?
-Let me see.
-I'm going to ultimately
regret playing this game,
but let me explain.
-Please.
-Let me explain shortly.
I had a new teammate
that I played with in 2002,
and he always had a gold thong
hanging from his locker.
And he told me,
"Anytime you struggle,
you wear the gold thong,
you're guaranteed to get a hit."
Now, I thought the guy
was crazy.
So, in 2004, I went through
the worst offensive stretch
in my career.
-Okay.
-And every day, I'd walk in,
he'd point at the thong.
So, finally, I wore the thong.
Now, it wasn't thong-to-skin.
I had shorts on underneath.
So I put the thong
over the shorts.
First pitch, home run.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, yes.
-No way.
-That is true.
-The golden thong.
-Yes.
-Wow!
I can't believe that's real.
Okay. Alright.
Which envelope should I open?
-Ooh, yeah.
-1 or 2?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
That's interesting.
I was hoping for 2, maybe.
Well, I don't even know
what they are.
[ Chuckles ]
-Why are you looking at me?
-I'm just laughing.
-Oh, okay.
-Where was this concert?
-It was in New Jersey.
-Indoor or outdoor?
-Outdoor.
-What era of
Red Hot Chili Peppers was this?
-Foo fighters opened for them.
-Oh. Oh!
-It was a great concert.
-Okay.
-I'd say 2000-something.
-What time of the year?
-This was summer.
-But Anthony never wears,
really, a top himself.
-That's true.
-So why would you
give him a top?
-He liked my shirt.
-Mm.
-And where did he put it?
-Wore it as a shirt.
-Where were you sitting?
-That's a good question.
I was on the side of the stage.
-Obviously.
-Well, I was on the side
of the stage.
I was talking to them.
He saw my shirt, wanted it,
said "I like your shirt,
I want that,"
or something like that,
and then, like, gestured to me
to give it to him or something.
-I don't believe it.
-What color was the shirt?
-It was a white T-shirt.
-Too many words.
You're using too many words.
-Sometimes, I use too many --
I'm a talk-show host.
-And I'm a huge --
[ Laughter ]
And I'm a huge
Red Hot Chili Peppers fan
and I love how focused Anthony
is onstage when he sings.
He's not going to notice you
on the side of stage.
-Oh, wow. I think, yeah --
-No, not in that way.
Not in that way.
No, no, no.
-I'm gonna say true
just so you got noticed. Yes.
-You're worried about my ego.
But here's the thing.
I took off my shirt.
He was not wearing a shirt.
So I thought, "Well,
I'll give him the shirt,
but he'll give me
something to wear back."
And he gave me nothing back.
So I'm standing there shirtless.
And I --
You know me a little bit.
I don't want to be
shirtless in public.
-You are talking too much now.
-What do you think?
You're talking way too much now.
I say it's not true.
-Yeah, me too. Yeah.
-You got me.
It's not true at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Talking too much.
-Yes.
-I was talking too much.
-You were talking way too much.
-I was talking way too much.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I planned the story out
all day,
this fake story,
and I just failed massively.
-Failed.
-Oh, I'm embarrassed.
Oh, my gosh.
You totally busted me.
It didn't happen at all.
Alright, alright.
Rita, it's now your turn.
Which envelope?
What do you think?
-What do you guys --
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-You totally busted me.
-1?
2? 2?
2. I can't hear. Can you --
-Someone's yelling "4."
so it doesn't even matter
at this point.
-I'm gonna go with 2.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
This one seems good.
♪♪
-Where was this?
-In New York City.
-Okay.
-I don't know
what accent that was.
-Yeah, it was like
a Southern accent, yeah.
But New York -- So, paparazzi --
Normally, you're running away
from paparazzi.
You went the other way
and said, "Let's be friends,
take me to the airport"?
-Well, it wasn't
a friendly exchange,
but it was a savior exchange.
I was being saved.
-Were you by yourself?
-No, I was with my driver,
driving me to the airport.
-I'm sorry.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, so you're with
your driver,
then the paparazzi
drove you to the airport?
-Hold on.
-Did they drive your car?
-That's interesting.
So there's two cars?
-No.
-Were you, like,
Jean-Claude Van Damme-ing,
two legs on both cars, cruising
through on your way to --
-Guys, guys --
-Where did you jump in the car?
-On the street.
-Yeah, in the city or --
-Like, on the motorway.
Highway. Highway.
-On the highway.
So you pulled over
on the highway
and then jumped in the car.
-And paparazzi pulled --
And you --
-And the paparazzi
pulled up behind me.
-You thought
you were safe enough
to get in the car
with paparazzi strangers?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-If any kid's watching at home,
never do this.
-No.
No, but this was
a really serious emergency.
-I hope I'm right.
-This was an emergency.
-What do you think?
-I hope I'm right.
-Okay, what?
-Yeah, me too. Yeah.
-I don't believe it.
-I don't believe it at all.
You would never, Rita Ora,
ever in your life,
ever risk -- You are a treasure.
You cannot risk getting in
a car with a stranger
ever in your life.
Is it true?
-It's true.
-Oh, my gosh!
Rita, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Were you scared? When was this?
-Explain.
-So, my car broke down.
And I had to catch this flight.
Like, I had to get
this flight back to London.
There was
a huge family emergency.
And I said to myself,
"Lord, help me if I make it
to the airport, but I have to
get on this flight."
And so I said to the paparazzi,
"This is so out of my character,
but I have no other way
to get to the airport."
-Well, you can't say
that anymore.
-Now the whole world knows.
"I have no other way
to get to the airport.
Please, can you drive me
to the airport?"
And he said,
"Jump in, let's go."
-Oh, my God!
-Wow!
-Thank you to that paparazzi.
Good for you.
My thanks to
Derek Jeter, Rita Ora.
Thank you for playing.